hello and welcome back to the shiki-san
show so today we're going to be getting
to know the circadian clock so we're
supposed to say that we live in a cyclic
world the Sun rises and the Sun sets
every day and around a 24-hour times go
well unless you live in the poles that
is and so we are diurnal creatures we
live during the daytime and sleep during
the night
whereas mice and other nocturnal animals
are well nocturnal and say they are
active during the nighttime and so on
this 24-hour times go we see changes in
the behavior physiology metabolism and
cell activity of different organisms so
for something to be occasionally
regulated it has to fulfill three
different criteria one it has have
persistent freerunning rhythms secondly
it needs to be able to be entrained by
relevant external cues so these include
things like the light and when you eat
and lastly it has to be temperature
compensated ie it can't be faster when
it's hotter and it can't be slower when
it's colder so as can be seen here on
the right-hand graph even as a higher
temperature the 24-hour rhythm remains
the same ie
its temperature compensated and so
research into the circadian rhythm can
be traced back to the 1700s but it was
only in 2017 when the Nabal Prize for
Physiology and medicine was given to
Jeffrey called Michael Ross patch and
Michael Young for their work on the
circadian rhythm and the key factors
involved so circadian rhythms are daily
fluctuations in behavior physiology
metabolism and cellular activity and so
these can be traced onto the clock also
known as the clock of health which shows
at what times of the day different
factors and mechanisms and processes are
happening in the body so as you can see
here I'm at 6 a.m. when you wake up you
have an increase in blood pressure which
is also correlating with the increase in
cortisol levels in the body you also
have high testosterone levels and higher
learners and say that Peaks around 10:00
a.m. and in the afternoon you have the
best coordination
as reaction times the greatest
cardiovascular efficiency and muscle
strength come to the evening and you
have the highest blood pressure and body
temperature and melatonin starts to get
secreted in the evening and this is your
sleep hormone and so finally before you
essentially go to sleep you have the
suppression of the bowel movements and
during sleep itself initially you start
with deep sleep followed by REM sleep
and this is where you have a low body
temperature before you wake up again in
the morning and so in addition to the
clock of health you also have the clock
of disease which is pretty much as a
consequence of the daily fluctuations
and different activities in the body you
have different diseases showing their
symptoms or phenotypes at different
times of the day as well
so for example where blood pressure and
cortisol levels are high in the morning
you also see an increased rate of people
having myocardial infarction and Gina
and sudden cardiac death in the
afternoon
there is an increased rates of
perforated gastric ulcers late in the
evening you have symptoms of chronic
pain and gout symptoms and in the early
mornings of the day you have the most
severe asthma symptoms and the most
severe depression but the key thing to
point out is that these different
symptoms and diseases are not restricted
to these times they're just when they're
most likely to happen based on how they
are circadian ly regulated in the body
but how does this regulation actually
come about so within a cell there are a
series of protein factors that
coordinates the 24-hour regulation of
the different processes within the cell
and so to provide a simplified overview
here there are four different key core
clock components that produce a negative
feedback cycle that enables the 24 hour
of regulation to occur so in mammals
these four main components are
cryptochrome periods clock and be male 1
so clock and be male 1 promote the
expression of cry and purr and then cry
Impa the protein products repress the
activity of clock and vemma 1 preventing
an expression and this negative feedback
with delay enables the around 24 hour of
regulation to the car although this is
just a simplified overview and it's a
bit more complicated and we didn't
really fully understand it yet but this
is just the basic introduction to the
core clock components this nature of you
article will provide you with a more
thorough introduction to these
components but as you will also notice
there is so much we are to learn about
the circadian rhythm which makes it a
really exciting topic to research so the
circadian clock is a way to coordinate
different processes so that they occur
at the adaptive time of the day for
example we don't want our body
temperature to be high when we're trying
to sleep at night
so hopefully this video has given you an
insight into the circadian clock